The
next excerpt is taken from original tape W one forty one side
two.
So you got married and if you're not fish and fish
and fish. You're clean and so round. Oh
yeah man you can do you finish one day. Please pack them in
your backpack you know a lot of times I don't finish of a day while.
We have to keep them separated but I don't finish one day we keep from a
certain place. Thank you and then what we fish a dead even in that
night you know we keep him in the refrigerator and then that morning when I
start playing him again I get that cleaned of ones that was left over from the day
before but you know they're all alive. So now you claim
they're alive. How do you know them well you just get the
servers and you cut her off as you just saw and or
did
man under a furnace and wash
them.
And I think it be
easier to raise a child
here than it would over on the mainland because
of and we're all friends and you know everybody
knows each other and that Ennis and if I want to so
you'll know why.
I never gave her a doubt
always thought of doubt was
a change fund was itching
you as
myself who are like you doesn't yet
have any. Yeah.
I was you. Are you are
you say
yes. And
I was disappointed that he didn't finish goal but he loves border business so
well and for him love in water business so well I think he's
going to be a good Waterman like his father because his father's next good for him.
And he's learned a lot.
I
guess too much now people have that have cars right here but I can't my yard to
low salt water comes in it too quick. Now I have four baskets
I used to have.
Pears
apples.
Great
on
chairs.
Take race. Oh yeah.
Yeah yeah yeah
that's true. Do you
think. Growing up.
And a difference.
Yeah. Change.
While the changes that I've been is in teenagers. I mean when I was growing up is that what you
mean because when I
was growing up.
And I don't I've been it.
And there was no going to through the week. And now
they go out every
night and it doesn't matter what time they get him. They have no
curfew no time limit.
Why do you think.
I don't know just time generations each generation
is deaf
or that I don't know. Well
yeah well that's that the deference is Nala
But
yeah the past is not as straight as it
were because our no friend of mine who graduated gather even one our
graduation her pass the name let her wear make up. But now there are
other children like you more America dad is Mom's and
more.
Just older.
Yeah
Yeah Yeahs words that may now I was the
youngest daughter is the oldest but I had two brothers Nate one
and younger now I know they say BOYS GET THE WAY more than
girls but I was never I mean both my brothers
was able to go I more often and things that I you know
I was unable to give them my mom dad just won't get it for me.
That they would do what they could for them you know it did make you feel funny and
think you know what it. Is the pants that they change.
Now I think it is because the way I feel now when Eddie
was born I was more stronger and felt more like. Strict.
But now that I get older you don't feel like all those power unfasten.
And you knew just war. And I
think a lot of that is that parents let the
young ones get away with. More than the older ones
because they just don't have enough energy
to continue on in the first and what that what
they do but continue talking to them and in
everything.
You
do
you
always roller skating skate dances ever Saturday
night ever started we
had that and
and
you know what you
bought. And in
the summer we would go swimming and to debate and have
picnics fission.
Parties
and then you know with have them there to
the community hall into the wreck
building that's another thing to change to when I was growing up we would
have birthday parties teenagers would have to write. You know the parents would give
them birthday parties but
now days they don't have them they don't have to birthday parties. You'll
find one it's no great
loss.
I just because the teenagers get anything they
want and use and when they get a part of it when I was growing that. Give
us a part of because we would get money that we would be able to buy more clothes than they
would we would get
off that now between would be able to get and I
think what's I have a part of to
do.
Today
Dr Rice
this is a case of things you know
questions in time going on day like
that I didn't know I don't know
the way out that.
My parents.
Yeah. I've been they
go to or like.
College and even though I'm staying over a year of school when
I
should go to court.
Yeah but still
if they
say yes. Tell them through your family again so I make sure I have a say
on the brother.
I have one
sister and she's the oldest. And I
have two brothers. They're younger than I
am OK junior
role. OK.
OK Did this family do a lot of
family
when I was young
not saying
I can remember when we did do that often was in the summer.
My father would take us.
And his Sunday. For us to ghost
woman and we would have like watermelon. Do you know for the children he would always take a
lot of children not only us but you know two or three.
Like I would have a friend to go with me my oldest sister would have a friend to go with
her you know and that and he would take us on a Sunday always in it but
they could never do it through the week because you know by the time he got in from crab and he's
just intended to scrap price he was just too tired to go because he works for a man a disparity.
But Sunday after church he would always take
us in his boat because that's what we love the most.
And
that is our main you know. And whenever I remember this to before we ever
learn how to swim mom would never let us go swimming with
even was a group of people that knew how to swim with side her she would leave her
high score
card issues you know clothes online she would leave everything and just get out to the
wharf and watch. You know until we learned how
to swim.
Yeah
very nerve or from a one time.
Yeah I was down on the end of war. At that time
swimmers cry out with a swim and on
top the wharf. Yeah on top of water. And they were called swimmers.
And used big boats would be up and then the channel just addressed in the right
and getting all the swimmers because they would be doublers good graduates woman and Algernon
and war for the crab
net and hours of get numb and this one time I went
to reach for that and over I went and at that time I didn't know how to swim.
So I mean the crab net went down and
Channel. And my job for Astro
thing got. Yeah yeah
there
was.
And that was before them but that made her realize you know she would
never let us ghost woman with
her unless she was aware that after we learn to
do some
more
only
going
back and forth. Chris Hill on the mail boat. You know if it was rough enough reason way
years ago we had the old one
but yeah she's up
there.
And one time I want to over there and it was
freezing and the boat was full of passengers and for
a everything she was loaded and I couldn't get in the cabin so they put
me with a lot of other
people that in the back of our war they have all this right.
And I was fine as long as I know I could get out. But they pulled that
latch over and hooked it and you couldn't get that eight. No matter what happened
you could get out and that was rough when the water begin to come
Ian and again
this.
Is ours by love on that lie that I was
little I was little but I never forgot it never forgot it
because I guess I know world was thinkin nobody can get at it you
know so I was a Slayer whenever I got on the boat and it's
rough to get out you make sure
that you know no matter what's going on I might add
that done so I'm a I'll never
forget.
I
EVER. It's been rough been
really tore me a
couple different ones.
And any
surprise. People.
But once you get afraid of the
war there are always the fear. You don't overcome that.
And
it is it's it's more people over here for the war the news than anybody would
realize in
talking because
we know what the water can do best when the
some are saying if you knew how to swim or have
a life jacket you more Michael would survive. But not when it's for a
reason there's no way you can survive
it and in the summer I can do pretty good with rough weather. I don't get
a frightened summer with threats and wonders when I get more frayed
because offending him there's you
know that.
You have a
lot done wonders we
do but this was been it's been ice some ice around
but not life where you have had it. We have been completely frozen for a week.
And what one time when you're out. I
mean had to get helicopters defraud or fly or when we were out of
a heating
oil.
People are you
know it's more wood stoves now in coal stove. Than it
was
back then it's cheaper
with our work over here. Yeah.
Over on the mainland they get it and then they get a big boat to bring it over then
they have
to get off the boat put it in the truck like you did or
high end to that.
And everybody.
Yeah. Yeah yeah I
strike is easier to get it flare you know that over here it's just tar.
Yeah yeah.
Now and then we had this storm here as a lot of people taken up the lawn.
You know for the.
Worst.
Yeah
that's when we had iceberg site here. Yeah
I agree. There
are some of those that
are still there.
Yeah yeah yeah you could doubt it
because we walked right across right now
right.
Yeah right in this corner here is not the bay there's not just a bottom
but after you pass that marshland over there. Then there is about
this.
Yeah we get on. But not as much as your
does always a year ago a year and a half
ago the drudge came in to judge this
challenge to bacon
there for their army and the
mainland people come in there their votes easier but it's all filled up
now they might be able to
sell and here on high
card because it's then raised that they had to hit him saying I was a
teller
voter.